[Music]
hello and welcome to another dw business
special once again we're talking about
russia continuing to put the squeeze on
gas supply and the european response to
that this week russia's state energy
supplier gazprom slashed gas supply yet
again to germany through the nordstream
one pipeline
germany's network operator says flows
have now sunk to just 20 of normal
levels that means it'll be difficult for
the country to fill its reserve before
the weather gets cold in germany and any
further reductions could trigger
emergency gas rationing
joining me now in our little studio to
discuss this is my colleague aaron
tilton hi erin and on the line we have
leon izbigi a natural gas analyst at
energy aspects
starting with you looking at the state
of europe's reserves how much of a blow
is this latest cut
it's it's still quite significant we're
talking about uh as you mentioned before
a
cut to only 20 of capacity via nordstrom
one and if that continues over for
example the rest of the injection period
and also throughout winter we are
looking even tighter on the european
balance in a situation in which there
might be an incentive for european
governments to actually trigger the
mandatory cuts for for rationing
programs
definitely not an ideal situation there
but aaron so turning to you you've
covered russia for quite a while how
likely is it that russia will cut off
supply completely i mean it'll hurt
europe for sure but then they can't use
that as a bargaining chip anymore sure
and i think to a certain extent it
really depends on how
europe and specifically germany reacts
to this threat into this cut because you
have to realize
despite what the kremlin claims it's
kind of dubious whether or not there are
actually technical reasons behind this
cut it does appear that vladimir putin
and the circle of people around him and
the kremlin are trying to put pressure
both on the eu and then also more
specifically on germany germany has
since the ukraine crisis started been
a rather well
they've held back some of their support
from ukraine which is they've often been
criticized by kiev4 and really i do
think that this is kind of a balancing
act for russia they're trying to figure
out um trying to see how germany and how
the eu will react to see if whether or
not they should actually carry out the
threat of uh well cutting off gas
supplies more broadly i mean you have to
remember vladimir putin doesn't
necessarily have a really long-term plan
he comes from that intelligence
community and they very much like to
just kind of give their opponents a
little bit of a shove see how they can
off balance them a bit and then decide
whether or not they should move forward
so i think the prospects of a complete
gas
gas cut off is going to be determined by
just how the politicians and how the
public here react
i suspect this isn't going to be the
first time in the show where i'm going
to be asking you to look into the state
of mind of the kremlin but now focusing
on germany in particular there's been a
noticeable attempt to try and prepare
the populace for a very cold and very
expensive winter here's germany's
economist economy minister robert habeck
is proving to be an unreliable supplier
but the gas volumes have been promised
to others and that means they still need
to be sourced at significantly higher
market prices and this difference is the
surcharge it will be passed on to
consumers because otherwise the
companies would face permanent losses of
many millions of euros every week and
that would eventually put them out of
business
ultimately we don't know exactly how
high the costs will be in november or
december but the bitter news is it will
certainly be several hundred euros per
household poor household
so that was germany's economy minister
robert habek leon back to you do you
have a sense of how prepared germany and
the rest of europe is for prices growing
as supply shrinks
well i mean what we can see in germany
in particular is as robert harvick
mentioned the preparation of the levy in
order to try and prevent systematic
shocks to uh german and european
stability utilities essentially as they
need to source spot volumes to make up
for the the missing volumes from russia
but what we are seeing more more
specifically is that this is also an
attempt to actually further reduce
demand among the european population
simply by increasing the overall price
burden for end consumers so if we are
looking at more reductions from the
residential and commercial sector this
would actually further help alleviate
the tightness in european gas markets
that that we're seeing at the moment and
i think the second component is more
generally speaking how prepared european
governments are at the moment
to to actually implement rationing
programs and i think this is still very
much a state of flux we heard repeatedly
from the bundesliga in germany that they
are still in the process of setting up
their portal to monitor daily
consumption from large-scale industrials
which is really needed in order to
actually implement rationing programs
and more generally speaking the current
programs that are in place focus on a
very short temporary suspension of flows
for example into germany whereas we are
here now talking about a prolonged
supply disruption from russia so that
will still probably take some time until
policy makers really are able to
adequately respond to these long-term
potential supply disruptions
so policy makers really should be
looking at a more long-term horizon
aaron i am going to ask you to look at
the russian side yet again so we're
looking at a world where russia is set
to permanently lose europe as a gas
customer can it afford to do that i mean
we can hardly assume that it's asian
trading partners can pick up the
shortfall there well that's actually a
really good point i mean we have seen in
the last several years last eight or
nine years uh continuing pivot from
moscow towards its asian partners you
know they've been courting india and
china for a long period of time right
now but when it comes to their energy
infrastructure they don't have the same
infrastructure in place that they do
with europe i think part of the problem
we're seeing right now is it really does
seem like the kremlin was expecting the
conflict in ukraine to be a rather short
affair they were expecting to take kiev
within five or six days and that didn't
happen they really massively
underestimated the resolve of both the
ukrainians and also the international
community when it comes to supporting
them so what we're seeing right now i
think is them being a little bit kind of
pushed into a corner they're having to
you know bring out larger and larger
weapons in a sense uh um to actually put
europe under pressure and continue that
to mount that pressure campaign against
ukraine as well so i don't think they're
really willing or able to lose europe
long term the problem is they're
involved in a very long conflict that
they weren't initially expecting to be
involved in
leon is that an assessment that you
agree with
i think
what aaron mentioned is is correct in
the sense that we are looking at the
fact that the main
bulk of russia's gas fields is really
connected only into
or majorly into the european market so
when we are looking at the potential
ramifications of a full flow hold for
example
we are in a situation in which russia
cannot divert those flows from europe
into other countries we we're looking at
for example flows into china actually
coming from fields in russia's far east
which are not connected to the to the
rest of the grid and the main pipeline
that would connect those fields in
western siberia into the chinese market
that is not expected to come online
until 2027 or 2028. so there are
significant economic ramifications for
russia if it were to decide to pursue
the avenue of a full flow hold but i
think what is also important to mention
and to stress in this case is
that
there is a risk of russia not
uh really following an economic
rationale anymore it
it has defied assumptions of rationality
with the invasion of ukraine it has also
demonstrated its willingness to breach
contracts with european suppliers so if
political considerations in terms of
actually aiming for a maximization of
harm that can inflict on on europe
before europe weans itself off russian
gas by taking more lng for example in
the us in 2026 2037 if that dominates
russian thinking then there is a
significant risk of a full flow halt
over the course of this winter and
potentially next year and uh if i may
interject and that's a point i
definitely agree with it has seen from
the get-go that this conflict is very
much um when it comes to the kremlin
rationale about vladimir putin's legacy
it does appear that he wants to be
a president and a leader of russia that
goes in the history books as in from
their view you know preventing a further
expansion of nato and also the exact
time he wants to just like peter the
great or catherine the great be
a russian leader who changes the borders
of russia it really seems like more than
anything as he's you know seeing his uh
career advance more and more he wants to
he's concerned about how the history
books are going to view him and his
legacy as well and i do think that's
feeling a lot of the rationale behind
this invasion of ukraine
that i guess is his grand design and the
economic implications or the economic
consequences out of that is something
that he is considering less now turning
back to us here in europe obviously
germany and eastern europe are much more
exposed to russian gas supply cuts than
say spain or portugal but this week
european union countries all together
agreed to cut back on gas consumption by
15
from august to march but this deal is a
much weaker version of an original
proposal put forward by the european
commission sparking concerns over the
potency of these commitments
our correspondent christine manuel
followed these proceedings in brussels
and here's what she had to say about
those concerns over effectiveness
the commission insists this plan will be
effective even if all of these
derogations or these exemptions are
exercised
at any given point and you're quite
right it has been watered down
significantly and at any stage in the
game virtually every single member state
could claim an exemption uh at a given
point but the commission is confident
that even in the case of that would have
happened that this plan would still be
effective to get europe through what it
is saying would be an average winter
leon i have a feeling i know what you're
going to say but do you see that deal
resulting in significant gas savings for
the block
i think it's it's important to
distinguish between the voluntary uh
reductions that the eu council aims for
and then the potential to implement the
mandatory reductions i think on a
voluntary basis
um i'm a bit pessimistic about actually
being able to reach a 15 cut in
consumption across europe and the main
reason for this is that it's quite
uncertain at this stage
what exactly policy makers are going to
offer to uh the the gas market overall
to consumers essentially
um in order to turn down consumption of
gas that the market itself in terms of
prices isn't already doing we are
looking at prices around 200 euros a
megawatt hour for the ttf so that is
essentially maximizing the switch from
gas to coal in the power sector
we are also looking at prices that side
that are actually incentivizing
industrials to turn down production and
to actually sell gas volumes back into
the market and it is also weighing on
end consumers for private households
that are looking probably at turning
down their domestic consumption over the
course of winter but all of that is
already baked into the current price and
we have already seen policy initiatives
in particular from germany where we have
brought back idle coal and lignite
forward capacity as well as oil fired
capacity to the market so what exactly
happens with to to reach that voluntary
15 demand cut is actually quite
uncertain and it looks not really
realistic the more important thing here
is really the ability for the commission
to impose a mandatory demand cut in case
of a union-wide emergency which will
help europe to actually
get through a situation such as a full
flow halt over the course of winter in a
weather normal scenario but then again
the question becomes how exactly is the
commission and how exactly are european
member states going to um coordinate on
on prolonged rationing across the
entirety potentially over the next two
three or four years until we can
actually replace russian gas and the
european gas balance from supplies from
elsewhere
okay so until the european union is able
to do that then it might be more useful
to think of this agreement as a
political signal but aaron how do you
think the kremlin views such a show of
solidarity or the solidarity that they
want us to see from the eu well to a
certain extent i think the kremlin and
vladimir putin kind of underestimated
the resolve both of the european union
member states of the european union and
also the united states when it comes to
supporting ukraine and as i was saying
earlier i don't think there was
necessarily as well developed of a
long-term strategy from the side of the
kremlin you have to remember this is a
this is a a government and a leader who
has spent millions and millions of euros
investing on investing in
trying to actually create derision um
within the european union that's why we
have seen the kremlin and other groups
in russia supporting far-right parties
here in germany uh in the united states
actually throughout the europe in
general and they've invested a lot of
money in just trying to so mistrust
when it comes to the um the conflict in
ukraine why i think they kind of
underestimated um what was going on is
you know ostensibly they didn't want
nato um to actually get a foothold in
ukraine which is part of the reason they
started this conflict at the same time
what they've seen what i guess they
probably didn't necessarily expect at
the beginning is states like finland
then saying that they were going to join
the block um i really do think that the
invasion of ukraine was a very
short-sighted and maybe uh well no very
poorly thought out move on the part of
vladimir putin and the kremlin and so i
don't necessarily think that they were
prepared for this level of solidarity
within the european union
well it is important of course that this
solidarity holds and it's all very well
to be able to reduce demand together but
many experts have argued for a way to
secure supply so european countries are
now focusing on using their energy this
energy resources at their disposal but
no one really thinks that's a long-term
solution so experts from think tanks
such as brugel have argued for a grand
bargain of sorts where member states
pool their energy resources no matter
what the source or where that energy
comes from so that would mean that coal
and nuclear are accepted for now even in
countries where they are unpopular
while europe builds up its green energy
infrastructure at a much faster pace
leon
turning to you
what do you think of this idea of a
grand bargain
well i think it's it's definitely
symptomatic of the
divergence between short to medium term
girls and and long-term goals in the
short to medium term it is about
guaranteeing energy security and policy
makers have been willing to actually
take a step back in terms of
overall goals and emissions reductions
for example in order to achieve and meet
that goal by bringing back coal-fired
power plants lignite fire power plants
mean oil-fired power plants that were
previously idled and in the long term
what the current situation with the
ukraine does is that it actually
accelerates the transition towards
renewable energies simply because they
are perceived to put europe in less of a
bind and less of a dependence on fossil
fuel imports from other countries
erin you were talking earlier about how
much the kremlin
underestimated the level of solidarity
that is present among the european
countries
is moscow going to make that same
mistake is moscow betting on europe
getting together for such a grand
bargain do they think they'll be able to
pull that
off
cooperatively well i don't necessarily
have a crystal ball but if i were
a betting man i'd say i don't think they
actually think that europe will long
term be able to wean themselves off um
russian gas entirely at the end of the
day i mean the status quo in russia for
such a long period of time is that they
were trading with the european union as
their main trading partner when it comes
to energy that um i think they think
when the conflict ends that we will see
a return to the status quo i mean most
of the russian government is oh 60 of
the russian government is rather funded
by sales of gas and oil to the european
union so i think in their
view this is a little bit of uh economic
and energy-based brinkmanship and they
think that when you know as it starts it
gets colder as gas starts get more
expensive and as um support for the war
in ukraine starts to wane that they'll
be able to return back to business as
usual now of course
i do think from the view of the european
union though that this is a real sea
change and um i don't think the kremlin
is really prepared for the long-term
ramifications of that
now we have to go in just a second but i
wanted to ask you guys any last words
leon any last point that you would like
to make before we leave our viewers
i think the the main question for
policymakers in particular when it comes
to considering this idea of a grand
bargain is
that
they have to be prepared to actually
implement uh relatively potentially
unpopular policies domestically as as
you've mentioned but one of the main
questions
that remains unresolved at this stage
for example in addition to
you know the obvious potential delay in
the nuclear phase out in germany
is the uh groaning and gas field and
whether there is a potential to ramp up
production from groningen simply because
this could actually help alleviate quite
substantially some of the tightness on
european markets and help reduce further
the dependence for europe on russian gas
but what the main takeaway of all of
this is is that actually in
the immediate short to medium term
europe still needs the marginal russian
gas molecule to actually balance to meet
demand
so the only way to actually cope uh in
in the short to medium term with a
potential further disruption supplies
from russia or even a halton flows
altogether is just demand rationing and
active demand side management so for for
policymakers and for the electorate it
becomes a question of whether uh they
are willing to to as i said sacrifice in
the short to medium term ambitions
regarding a potential pivot towards
renewables
for an actual alleviation of the overall
inflationary and price burden on end
consumers and on the european economy as
a whole
i really do think that's a great point i
mean at the end of the day what we're
seeing here is that the european union
really and those politicians are really
going to have to kind of bite the bullet
and be willing to have the resolve to
push through policies which are not
going to be very popular among their
electorate i mean we're seeing gas and
heating prices here in germany spiral
out of control i mean i just moved to a
new apartment and suddenly i'm paying
literally eight times more to heat my
apartment than i was a year ago at this
time and i think that's really what the
kremlin wants to do they're kind of
hoping that by putting economic pressure
of this sort on the electorate that they
can actually kind of put pressure on
berlin and the other capitals in um
europe to move away from the support of
ukraine and you know if the european
union really wants to make sure that um
we don't return to a situation um where
you know a rogue state can change the
borders of another country by military
force they're going to have to have um
oh the hutzpah to just force through
policies that their electorate isn't
really going to want to support
necessarily but that's exactly what the
kremlin's challenge to the european
union right now is trying to do
fascinating stuff we can talk about this
all day but unfortunately we'll have to
leave it here for now that's all we have
for you for this week from our little
business desk we'll be back here with
another dw business special for you next
week thanks a lot to my guests leon
izbiki and aaron tilton if you'd like
more please hit the like and subscribe
button i'd also encourage you to check
out the dw business series here on
youtube business beyond which takes a
look at business phenomena shaping the
globe for me and the whole business team
in berlin thanks for watching